toxic elements test the gadelle idiom
obviously you can see there is very very
high on there on the reference range
Richard believes he was poisoned by a
scam that was supposed to help him gadda
lynnium has given to improve images and
around 30% of the more than two million
patients who receive an MRI scan every
year the NHS says it's safe but Richard
says it made him profoundly ill his
symptoms began with involuntary muscle
twitching gadda lynnium poisoning the
leg and then deteriorated leaving
doctors baffled I was lying in a
hospital bed my muscles literally firing
away like anything really bed down at
this point with very limited mobility
I had fibromyalgia front of me Emme
which is chronic fatigue the assumption
was that I had motor neuron disease to
the point where MND was written above my
bed and my wife had you know nurses
crying next to her Richard did not have
motor neurone disease which is a
terminal condition but tests revealed
did have high levels of gadolinium in
his system it is a rare-earth metal
which ordinarily is highly toxic
when used in MRI scanning the gadolinium
molecules are bound to proteins a
process known as chelation and then
injected into the bloodstream this
improves the image captured by the
scanner the gadolinium should then pass
out of the patient system via the
kidneys in urine but there is evidence
the gadolinium can be retained in the
body and deposited in tissues bones and
the brain
Katrina Walsh was a pediatric consultant
when she began suffering from chronic
pain and exhaustion today she controls
her symptoms with nutrition but traces
her illness to an MRI with gadolinium I
was incredibly anxious about the future
because I suppose with my medical
background and you know I know the
gadolinium is a gun free gadolinium not
only in the setting of contrast agents
is is a very very toxic heavy metal and
I also know that it can come out of the
contrast agents and inside the body so
you have this free gadda lynnium that
can cause I have it have it this
hospital in London has the only NHS
laboratory in the UK that tests for
gadolinium and a Freedom of Information
request given to Sky News shows that the
number of people testing positive though
small is growing
they've been 8 this year already and the
medicines regulator has told us that
several types of gadolinium contrast
agent have been banned following a
review and radiologists told only to use
it when absolutely necessary and at the
lowest possible dose the risks from
gadolinium contrast as long as we're
giving them to the right patient for the
right indication then they're very very
low and you have to counterbalance them
about the benefits of the scan not
knowing the diagnosis that you've come
for a scan to try and sort out is a risk
and you have to balance the benefit of
the scan and the risks that are
associated with the scan against having
the contrast having the scan at all
currently patients are not warned that
gadolinium can stay in their system
Richard and Katrina say that at least
must change patients should certainly
receive a lot more information on it and
that the uncertainties ethically you
have a huge issue on your hands you have
to tell people that they have this in
them MRI scans have helped save
countless lives but a growing number of
patients want reassurance that the
rewards still outweigh the risks
Paul Kelso Sky News